[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
Rhett this week at the round table of
dim lighting we will be answering your
questions about
now whether you are in college have been
in college or might consider one day
going to college I think you can benefit
from the conversation we're gonna have
using questions submitted by many
mythical beasts as a stopping ground for
ideation yeah advice a ssin you guys are
bringing it and reminisce nation you
know we went to college we can you know
it's gonna take us back to that place
again we've got some experiences that
may offer some perspective that may or
may not be helpful but either way
hopefully you're going to be entertained
but the thing that I love about getting
the questions from the mythical beasts
is it it because a lot of times what we
hear them say is there we hear mythical
beasts saying things about the stuff
that we put out on the Internet right
uh-huh
because if you're just reading comments
you're just getting lots of opinions
right good bad and different about the
stuff that you're doing but when you go
out and you ask a specific prompt like
this there's it's like a little little
picture a little picture into there a
little window into the lives of a
mythical beast yeah and if if you're
wondering how you can respond to those
prompts that's Facebook Twitter maybe an
Instagram I don't think we do it on
Instagram but lots of pictures on there
so you should follow us over there too
yeah we got cool pics man picks every
day and hopefully the light won't crash
down on us this week well we've been
told it has been secured with a it's
like a metal plate up there yeah I see
it's bolted five four six there's six
screws in that actually they're only
used four screws do you know what I'm
pretty sure it's very secure let's take
a question link right off the bat now
last time we didn't say last names
because those but we shouldn't say last
names yeah look because there's some
roommate complaining going on
here yes sir there's some there's some
real situations that we're gonna have to
rectify it's gonna get so let's leave
some you'll let's leave some last names
off charros leaving off the last name
hey rhett and Link hey I'm gonna be
moving into a rental house with four
other people for this school season Oh
Charles cause this it's a season like
it's a sporting maybe he's an athlete at
the leat thing there's only one bathroom
Oh
with four people how do I assert my true
bathroom domination from day one very
interesting question well Charles you're
on the right track here in just
identifying that this is going to be a
problem there's four of you there's one
bathroom and what you do at the very
beginning when it comes to the bathroom
the apartment situation you name it
those first few days maybe weeks those
are important times that's that that's
that's the sweet spot to set the right
precedent but dou u dou you do you not
think that Charos is potentially
stepping into the water on the wrong
foot I'm trying to make it by trying to
make a bathroom analogy it didn't work
stepping into the toilet water stepping
into the deep end so to speak of the
bathtub by saying how do I assert my
true bathroom domination because your
bathroom have a deep end by the way yeah
your your back to my bathtub yeah I had
it installed so I could I think there is
a standard there is a slight deep end
and it's the end with the drain right
it's only very slight so mine goes down
like another foot special special you
know well how does that water get out
yeah that's where the drain is oh oh wow
you're on a slope I'm making it all up
okay way it's a normal bathtub but I
think the problem is is that if everyone
cut again this is uh I can't remember
what kind of ethics this is my brain is
not working today
stupid ethics but when you basically
evaluate if everyone were to bring this
perspective to the situation there'll be
trouble to be trouble so everyone comes
in with I want to dominate the
bathroom you were actually sitting here
you have to come in saying how do I get
bathroom tranquility not bathroom
domination I think you're asking the
wrong question right off the bat because
I don't even know what yeah I think I
think you're approaching this wrong you
just can't dominate because then your
friends will your roommates will hate
you by the way I don't know what
bathroom domination means I the thing
that I thought it meant before well I
think either a big burrito oh gosh well
that can't be what the temporary is
referred to here I think it's you got
one sink I'm gonna put all my stuff
around there you know now I will say
after sharing I mean we shared a
bathroom in Cup in college our first
three years we were in a dorm we were on
a hallway and we shared a bathroom with
everybody on the hall but then our
junior and senior sophomore junior
senior year we moved into an apartment
with two other guys and then added a
fourth guy mm-hmm
and so in in that situation I was
sharing a bathroom all three of us were
sharing a bathroom no no no you had your
own
me and Tim shared about two had a
bathroom but we share and Greg and I
shared a bathroom yeah the one that when
we got when we left the apartment we got
charged and one of the items that we got
charged like thousands of dollars for
was we took grip tape that you put in
the bottom of a bathtub when there's a
shower so you don't slip and we spelled
our names
yeah being the greatest him didn't live
with us initially and we didn't remove
that and then they charged us hundreds
of dollars to remove that and if they
took a picture of it there were ever any
doubt as to who was responsible for this
particular form of vandalism
it was Rhett Lincoln Greg because that's
what it said in the bottom of the bath
so here's what I think I think you
shouldn't you gotta be you got to be
diplomatic about this okay you you got
your you're forming a life at least for
a year in a living situation with these
three other people so you can't dominate
the bathroom but you can set the tone at
the top how it how it work
and I think it comes down to two words
caddy system oh gosh I was gonna say the
exact same thing yeah one can leave
anything on the sink everyone has their
own container just like in the dorm
because I'm gonna bring on the hallway
you know do you bring it from your room
or do you put it in a drawer and take it
out
I must I'm going worst-case scenario
there's not enough room for everybody
stuff you put in your room in your room
and you bring you bring your little
travel companion kit we call it a kit in
the McLaughlin household Oh
here's the difference we take it in a
cat a kit zips up a caddy is open-faced
ok caddy like Nettie's good the breads
not on top of the sandwich so to speak
the thing I like about the kit is that
if I have to go away for the weekend you
already got I've got it all together but
access is an issue with the Caddy it's
all there it's all I have a caddy now by
the way you have a caddy in your own in
my phone I have my own sink Kristy has
her own saying we have to smoke you out
there your bathroom your bathroom is
massive I have a huge employer
racquetball in your bathroom I have a
caddy and the irony is might be going a
little too far we have pedestal sinks
this is how they were before we did not
design this oh it's just a sink that
then at the edge of the sink it just
zips down like a Vaz to the floor no
surface and then there's this underneath
the mirror there's a three inch deep
glass shelf in front of my sink and
Kristy sink and after being in the house
for six months Lincoln somehow put
something on the glass and literally
broke the glass shelf on my sink so I
have nothing I have well you just left
it I just left it because because
Chrissy and I were saying we're gonna
remodel this bathroom
yeah and lo and behold three years later
nothing and I have no shelf I have I
have literally if I ball my fist up and
put it on either side of the the two
faucet handles that's how much room I
have enough room for a little soap and
then like a little something like where
do you put the caddy when you go to the
bed where do you keep the caddy then
where do you put the kisser
there's no sink there's a little shelf
there's a it's a floor shelf thing that
we
like an Ikea crappy type thing that we
put in between the zoo sinks and there's
enough room for me to put my caddy down
and use it and pick it up and then
Kristi put stuff down there but where
does a caddy go when it's not in use
into a shelf with a door on it somewhere
else in the bathroom yeah seven steps on
a closet
seven steps away yeah caddy in the
closet like a movie I really it I really
hate it yeah but but you know what it it
keeps me on my toes man you got it you
don't want you don't keep any every
here's the thing if you just have
drawers and countertops galore like you
have in your house you accumulate a
bunch of crowd and you wouldn't you
don't you wouldn't believe encounter
looks and it's just strong everywhere
I've got I think I have believed in
caddy seventeen and twenty appointments
that I apply to myself every day and and
you got twenty more that you stopped
using you don't really don't even need
them anymore but the right I got so much
space I just put creams and ointments up
there only might as well put that on my
body if we can if I can use the Caddy
system now and Rhett aspires to use one
one day then it's good for you to go
ahead and start doing that now and
Charles go ahead and buy three more for
your other roommates and saying you know
what you don't have to use this you can
buy any type of caddy or kit with a
zipper that you want but I just wanted
to give this to you
that's a way to assert your dominance
but I'll call it leadership because now
you're you're making a sacrifice a few
bucks out of your wallet in order to
keep you know everybody is there a
little bit
it's an incredible plan you take the
initiative but you give them the tools
to follow through with your your
initiative that that is the perfect plan
now we're gonna get into another
question here in a second but we got
some good ones we're gonna let you know
about something we're gonna let you know
about mythical dot store support
entertainment and get a brand new hat
now this is what they call the dad hat
and which ironically is not for dads as
you'll see here in a second
while a lot of people love these and
that's why we have them because they
were demanded super cool man they're
ironic to be worn I don't look good in
this hat now this is probably not the
best way to sell it
let me just
knowledge that right up front but I have
a sort of like a horse-faced situation
like this a little bit long and my hair
creates the Elizabeth barrels on top of
my head and the hair on the bottom of my
face they create this illusion of head
that doesn't exist right I have no chin
and I got to actually have a rather
small head so and when I put this on you
can tell that's why I don't wear I wear
hats that have a large high crown but
not everybody likes that let me see how
you look in this I think I would look
bad too because now I have your
hairstyle I'll do it no but you have a
lot more forehead than I do so I think
that you've actually got head up there I
mean it doesn't look like you look like
a dad yeah it doesn't look like a link
stir kind of approach to things
but a lot like the guy who shows up at
like the recreation soccer game to watch
his kid keeps his hands in his pockets
the whole time we are selling the crap
out of this hand right now look great on
you if you're not a dad if you're a cool
person you know it got cool when you did
that oh really you popped it up like
this did you mean to do that well I did
it instinctively yeah that's yeah are
you serious
it's better yeah yeah on you what about
this Oh fresh press very great yeah very
good
yeah you leave the tag on yeah I don't
know why Jacobs laughing I don't think
you can leave the tag on a dad hat
though but we've got the tag on this one
just to let you know it is new and it is
available at mythical dot store also got
these two t-shirts check those out oh
yeah let's get back into this Levi's I'm
a sophomore in my engineering technology
degree program engineering and there
tends to be lots of group projects this
quarter common thing in college he's
creeping its way into the high school
and middle schools group work how can I
politely deal with partners who
constantly overcomplicate every detail
of the project thereby slowing down our
progress
I thought Levi was gonna say how do I
deal with people who don't want to
contribute which is a different problem
this one there they got there they're
too nitpicky you're slowing down you're
gumming up the works this is it this is
a problem group projects present their
own special set of problems because
comes down to the individuals who make
up that group now let me just I'll just
give you a little story from my traffic
engineering class oh I'm listening now
oh yeah I got ya I got ya put me like a
like meat on a hook yeah in a metal hook
well you could have you could have made
a traffic analogy that would have been
better you hooking me like like a u-turn
not a highway okay so yes part of the
civil engineering degree at NC State
University or at least the track that I
was on had a traffic engineering
component and this was a whole class
where we studied traffic like lights
like traffic lights like how you
determine how long things should be
green or red and and we also had the
final project for the year was
completing the 64 bypass the highway 64
bypass which I'm pretty sure 20 years
later does exist now mm-hmm
but at the time it didn't so it was
connecting highway 64 from like east of
Raleigh to like way out and Clayton or
yeah I don't know just that part of the
town and so the group project was to
take a map basically and use all the
things that we had learned in the class
to decide where exactly we were going to
route the new road and then to do the
topographic like map of where it was
gonna be and where the bridges were
gonna be you know and what the expenses
were going to be and how much you're
gonna have to pay for this thing and how
you avoid this graveyard and all that
stuff how many how many like farmers
with their cottages you're gonna have to
force off yeah because it was really a
game of Who am I going to inconvenience
and how do we keep the cost down you
have to pay certain people off and you
have to avoid certain wetlands and
environmental concerns and the craziest
thing is the cemeteries this is one
thing I learned is that you can't move
those well you can't go but you've got
to stay away from cemeteries and like if
there's a cemetery and it's in a
situation it's like you cannot impinge
or infringe on that Cemetery up for
obvious reasons but just something you
don't think about until you get into it
titillating traffic engineering class
but here's what I learned I got
partnered up with Karen and someone else
I can't remember her name do you
remember Karen and what I learned very
quickly in our first meeting is that
these two women had this had the subject
matter so wrapped they they understood
everything that we were going to do they
knew exactly what they wanted to do when
they were deathly afraid of the final
presentation day one I said guys here's
the deal you do all the work and I will
do all the previous presentation and it
was like told him that yes because they
were worked oh because because they
could tell they had all these ideas I
was like I'm gonna stay out of the way
they're super nervous about the
presentation I said I will get up I will
do all the talking I will take full
credit I'm going to tell all of your
work I'm gonna tell jokes I'm gonna be
able to synthesize this information in a
way that gets the got this is one of my
highlights in college oh yeah so this is
a really really boring class super
boring class I can't tell I don't even
remember exactly what I did I just know
that I had a whole routine about this
highway and the professor who had never
laughed at a presentation was doubling
over and laughter throughout this entire
presentation and you know what grade I
got in traffic engineering on the
presentation and in the class hey plus a
plus you Boop that's what I got I got an
A plus because but you couldn't have
done it without Karen and what's her
name you know right but yeah I'm nice so
I'm bringing this back to the advice
okay division of labor that's you're
still up you're saying right up top yeah
you need to have that who's good at work
you need to have a skills assessment
conversation yeah where it's like okay
what are your expectations what are you
what what is what are you willing to
invest what are you bringing to the
table right let's divide this thing up
so that everybody's not trying to do
everything if somebody's like you know
I'm really into the details and somebody
else is like well I'm really into the
details like well only one of you
be really into the details well I got
the problem here I don't know exactly
how you should break it down it may not
be as clean of a breakdown as it was for
me I'm just I'll make it pretty clean
okay I'll boil it down to two words two
words caddy system okay so have a candy
system for the group I don't know how
yet but somehow you get everybody in the
group gets a caddy you're talking I'm
talking toothbrush sleepover I don't
recommend that no but I I think you're
right you know I I don't remember that
much group work happening in my
engineering class there wasn't a lot but
I do remem I do remember we had to
design in I think it was my the course
was called facilities another fun one oh
yeah it was we took it was a whole
listen it was a whole course daughters
how you take like a physical environment
where something is being manufactured
and you set up the manufacturing process
physically within the facility so do we
need to buy fork trucks to move things
or do we need to put conveyor belts in
and I remember telling them I'm gonna do
the presentation I didn't go as far as
you did like I actually worked on stuff
because I was with a couple of my
friends I mean I did I did some it
wasn't it wasn't that clean I do
remember at one point you had to load a
bunch I can't remember what we were
making but it had all these like
different powders and big bins that had
to be moved from point A to point B and
so I found this roller bin that dumped
on the internet and I was like all right
I was really proud of this thing my
whole presentation hinged around a
dumping roller bin that you bought and
used in the presentation no I just put
it in the PowerPoint oh there was no
real money involved there was no real
facility involved this is all
imagination got it virtual but I
remember I showed a picture of the been
undone and then I showed a second
picture of the been dumped and I
remember saying look at this roller Ben
that dumps he's not yet dumping
and look then it's dumping watch the
been dumped dumped and I went back and
forth you did like a Letterman thing
like dump undone yep dump I'm dog I did
I did that and um it was basically like
a jiff before you invented it I invented
the gif and I called it a jiff and I got
a lot of puzzled looks oh so it so at
the end I don't think we got a seat it
didn't go over we might have got a B I
don't remember I think you're right you
got to have right off the bat you just
got to have the conversation how are we
gonna divide this up and we all got to
be in on everybody's got to pull their
way I do want to I do want to make that
clear everybody's got to pull their way
I think me doing the presentation was
pulling a lot of weight ask Karen and
what's her name they'll tell you here's
another one Alicia I'm an agricultural
major animal science to be specific we
had that at NC State and I have to spend
the night in the horse barn to keep an
eye on the pregnant horses Oh in case
they give birth now this is much more
exciting than anything we did let me
just tell you right off the bat well at
certain points it is how can I be
comfortable and get some sleep in a
horse barn this I mean this is what
college is all about well not usually
camping out at the Heinen of a pregnant
horse I mean it just sleep right there
at at the bet the rear and you you'll
wake up when you need to trust me I
think it might be too late once the
afterbirth is is all over you I mean oh
yeah can you sue first of all can I be
comfortable guess is that what bunch up
some hey girl well some hey horses sleep
standing up my do horse majors sleep
standing up oh that's the question that
art of it this is like a this is like a
science for ordinary t-shirt I called
her a horse major first of all which is
probably not what she calls herself
that's like a pick-up line
I'd like the AG yeah school hey baby do
you sleep standing up I don't know where
that where you go with that one though
yeah when you're when your pickup line
involves the word sleep you're in you're
in trouble you want
you want to see me sleep standing up
like a horse you know in what way I'm
like a horse that's what your horse
that's what you're looking for and it's
not what you're taking do you know in
what way I'm like a horse we just said
it and then on the back of the t-shirt
it's not what your thought and then do
you give the answer or is that in
conversation you asleep standing now he
has to ask she has to ask I sleep
standing up
my grandfather my papa Neal he tells the
story of it's got to be like nine
siblings back in the day when they were
on the farm they're in the same bed the
parents would just keep having children
and they literally the children would
start taking care of the other children
and then they'd start working the farm
and he tells all these stories but he
talks about at night
Hey I mean North Carolina's not always
cold but it gets cold and so they are
they all slept in big beds where the
mattress was made out of hay right I
mean it's amazing how quickly things
have changed in just three generations I
don't know about you but I don't sleep
on hay well not not usually there's
Thursday nights right hey if you really
get in trouble right you have to go
sleep on the hay yeah
yeah every night man so that's my answer
Alicia well that she didn't ask how do
you sleep she how do you how can I get
comfortable and get ya that is what she
asked yeah I answered I think hay hay is
the punch up - hey girl
but you're doing you're way ahead of the
game Alicia because I think you're doing
something that is immediately fulfilling
as I as I picture it birthing a horse
Ethan
one of my suitemates has friends friends
as in quotes over almost every day and
when their quote hanging out she's very
loud okay see where this is going
and she sounds like a dying dog my other
sweet mates and I don't really know what
to do should we tell her that we can
hear her should we call animal control
should we pretend like it's not
happening but record her mating call
there you go
another clue is what's going on and
randomly start playing it in the middle
of the forest and see what animals come
help I've got some thoughts on this I
have some questions that I'm not here
today I don't think Ethan is here to
respond I mean right off the bat I will
say that this is what they call free
entertainment rat I'm just hey listen
this is not the cut why are you
listening to a podcast when you could
listen to your sweet mate and friends my
votes I'm just saying if this was me
lying dog you ever heard a guy know he'd
come sure doesn't sound that bad it
sounds actually kind of sad all I'm
saying is that if this was me and this
was something that this was a sound that
I might hear from the next room just
just receive the blessing you know what
I'm saying just just let it just let it
wash over you and just be like good for
them and you know don't try to stop it
and don't I wouldn't say anything about
it now maybe maybe I can't put myself in
anything shoes maybe it's it's so
overwhelming but I gotta say that when
we lived it gorman crossings that's
where we lived in NC State apartment
3000 see yep if you want to go by and
check it out and the apartment above us
there was some things that happened in
that apartment and directly above where
I where my room was uh-huh and it was a
pretty regular occurrence and to me it
was just like putting a little quarter
in them and a machine you know what kind
of machine just you know a machine that
made noises it's like a noise machine
well I think a neighbor your hands are
kind of tied maybe maybe the neighbors
too but I think if it's your roommate I
is a suite mate this suite mate
situation smacks of smack cesare
probably oh not a good
inconsiderate man and there's a there's
a level of I mean if this is happening
every day and the dogs dying every day
then that's a that's a tad bit
inconsiderate it smacks of that now they
did did he say that he said something
no he's just asking what they should do
first of all do not record it and play
it for animals that was not worked well
I'll tell you from personal experience I
I thought that was a pretty good idea
I'm pretty interested in that science
experiment
well don't you don't publicize it maybe
just play it in the forest we don't sell
tickets to it but don't ya you don't put
it on the internet definitely you can
get that's illegal calling animal
control is a genius passive-aggressive
move especially if they Co all the way
into the room the dogs dying right now I
don't know whose dog it is get in here
Animal Control shows up with a net I
think that put a stop to it there's a
kibosh on that well that's kind of like
swatting Kabam
you know this yeah it's like mild
swatting and swatting not cool is highly
illegal it's like a major felony
you cannot call the SWAT oh if you if
you if you say that there's like a
situation going on at somebody's house
does that apply to animal control - no
I'm saying that it's not a SWAT is a
mild swatting calling animal control is
a mild swatting so it's probably a
misdemeanor so I can't we cannot advise
okay let you break the law you can't
unnecessarily call animal control just
because she sounds like a dog I've got I
got two words you always like to go to
the two words okay I'm listening
sound blankets oh I thought you guys a
caddy system no I would never have said
that yeah but you know now that you
mention it caddy system maybe you just
give them a caddy system that has a
sound blanket in it lots of I just think
they need to decorate their room would
sound blankets I mean everybody wins
it's warmer in there it's and the sound
to sound done come out I mean you got a
soundproof it and you can go in
fifty-fifty on that okay I do think you
got to talk about it
Justin I keep want to say two last names
but I'm not but I like the way you just
left it Justin Justin has a question
my roommate refuses to
empty the lint trap now is this another
euphemism for the same thing I doubt it
okay this is probably literal refuses to
empty the lint trap because I don't know
how that would be a euphemism for it
well emptying the lint trap I think is
it euphemism for something but what's
the lint trap I'll tell you later how do
I properly explain the importance of
lint trap maintenance without seeming
like a jerk well yeah I don't think your
concern is seeming like a jerk I think
you can your concern is seeming like a
an over controlling goody two-shoes now
let me tell you how to use the lint trap
now I can I can say this because I am
this person I am 100% in charge of the
lint trap at my house every time I go
through my you know my passageway of the
garage that I've talked about has the
the the dryer in it and every time that
that thing's got some dry clothes in it
or there's wet clothing the other one I
always am happy to transfer it in there
and I'll always remove that lint trap
but you know what there's lots of times
when I can tell that that lint trap has
been run for three cycles there's so
much lint trapped in that thing it's
it's hazardous now and I could take it
around everybody in my house and I could
say look what you did we could this
isn't caught on fire but I I've lost
hope and I just take I take pride in
staying on top of it myself so I've
given a clarifying question but I'm not
in college by doing it by being the only
person who does it have you rendered the
rest of the family like basically
incapable of and now like if you go away
for an extended period of time like if
are they wrestling that's Jessica is
everybody at risk now just because you
haven't you haven't done it because
Justin Rhett makes a good point don't be
like me I'm not I'm not saying don't be
late link I'm just saying that because I
am also the lint trap guy in my house
really yeah because every time I lick
your finger before you remove it no I
don't I'm sure I do not have as
developed of a system as you do because
if you don't lick your finger first
you're scraping for a long time you're
like a raccoon pawing at a
a box that has a cake in it I just get a
corner in pull and it all comes off well
that sounds like you've got two or three
cycles on it I definitely have two or
three cycles because I'm the guy and I'm
not as attentive to detail as you are
but so we may be going five six cycles
in my house you are in the danger zone
so I think the answer to this question
is I think you've got to again I think
you've got to potentially fake a fake a
situation oh gosh I think you've got to
I think you've got to put on some you
got to get some some clothes and and
like char them in certain places and
you've got to just in the middle of the
night one night run in grab your
roommate and say get up get up there's a
fire there's a fire because we didn't
change the lens in the dryer and then
he's gonna panic and you're being you've
already been burnt because you're
wearing the clothes yeah yeah you look
you need to look a little burnt okay
you'll have to do makeup I'm just saying
just a little char eNOS okay you know
that can be done in the t-shirt and
there's a t-shirt with some char on it
like a nipple peeking through you can
smell a little bit like smoke if you
wanna get some liquid smoke and just use
it like Cologne okay that's another
option you freak him out he gets up he
thinks that the place is burning down
and then right before he gets out the
door you say psych but that's how
serious this would be because you never
change the lint trap now again I don't
know about the legal repercussions of
faking a fire you cannot do that in a
public place because that's illegal I
was I think you can say fire just to
your roommate you can do anything I
don't know we don't not legal experts
especially if he doesn't go in and tell
the authorities I was actually gonna say
gather up all that lint that he should
have removed over three cycles and then
put it in the middle of his floor and
burn it
flammable wood is not flammable it's
again I think that should come with a
warning Tracy hi guys hey I teach intro
to sociology at Pennsylvania Highlands
Community College I'm listening
sometimes it can be challenging to hold
students attention any suggestions for
making learning more fun in the
classroom
I'm not gonna make any Community College
jokes okay because I could say something
like well because you're teaching at a
community college I see how this is a
problem but I'm not gonna say I know I
won't say anything like that
Tracy seriously I I think I think I have
some good advice that comes from my
father who is a law professor who has
been teaching for an incredibly long
time like since 1980 and so we're
talking almost 40 years of teaching
experience and now I don't know
necessarily if this is the he basically
uses the Socratic method to teach which
is what does that mean it's basically
like calling on people and having a
discussion a conversation and you know
it's a little old-school but here's the
thing that I think is great about this
so every single day and I don't know if
he still does this I haven't talked to
him about it in a while but you ever
talk to him period you should talk to
you I'm not talking to my dad right now
just kidding
it's not we should joke about it's not
something we should joke about but we
did okay
so in any given class that my dad is
teaching he may call on you oh no
there's no raising of hands no so he's
like okay he gives a homework assignment
or you know he's or the reading
assignments talking about these are the
cases that you're supposed to read this
week and then Tuesday morning rolls
around and then he's sitting there and
he's teaching and he's like mr. Neil
what do you think and then he asked a
specific question at that point mr. Neil
has to stand up in class and he says
sometimes the entire class will be one
student standing up and him just asking
them questions and having a discussion
the entire class with one person
standing up that he has done that before
that it's got to make some people crap
their pants but you know what it does
Tracy but if you're gonna be a lawyer I
guess but not all lawyers get up and
speak in front of people they're not all
orators yeah but here's the thing is
that he's actually told me that like
this particular approach is a little bit
as
been people have tried to discourage him
from doing it because it does put
students in an uncomfortable situation
but he's old school and he's like well
that's what they need to be put into an
uncontrolled situation if they're trying
to be good at this job they need to be
able to be grilled and to take these
questions and be able to answer them now
I'm not saying you have to go as as old
school and as strict as Professor
mcLaughlin but I do think that makes my
pits wet right now just thinking about
but I mean we're talking about sociology
at Pennsylvania Highlands Community
College ok so I think that we're in a
situation where we can expect someone to
I think you should just call on people
Tracy honestly I think that's what you
should do I think there should be random
times in any given class where you're
like mr. McLaughlin or whatever you call
your students and then ask that question
you don't have to make them stand up but
just let them know that they could be
asked a question at any time you will
immediately have this new sense of
authority as the professor in this class
and they will have this immediate
respect and because no one likes to look
stupid
no one will in the end you know what
then the people who aren't preparing
sometimes not kind of do okay that
explains a lot but I'm just throwing
that out there food for thought I think
that would be a way to get people to
perk up and pay attention and know they
can be called on at any time Tracy just
try it a little bit if you're gonna take
Rhett's advice and remember that it
wasn't my advice Taylor I'll take credit
for it I'm graduating from film school
in the spring congratulations
mm-hmm and I have no idea what I'm going
to do after college probably so you
should do something film yeah you should
do something film yeah do something film
for the first time ever I won't be in
school and that's kind of scary how do
you decide what to do with your life
when school no longer dictates
everything you do you know this this is
real I mean Taylor's right you you spend
your whole life just being taught at
scheduled everything and learning and
maybe you've had a job maybe you've had
a full-time job but or something that's
flirted with job eNOS
but it's different when it's like okay
I'm not a student anymore I'm just out
there for me
in my junior year they they presented
all the engineering students with the
co-op program which was you take us um
you don't take a semester off you're
technically still a student but instead
of taking classes you find a job and
they help you find a job somewhere for a
semester and then you come back and you
take another semester classes so it it
along gates you're your student career
before you move on to your bona fide
career by probably another year but it's
like it's a it's more of a soft
transition into full-time work as
opposed to a hard transition from school
to work I'm obviously not advising this
to you Taylor because you're about to
graduate but this is my perspective was
I was interested in that because I could
I could start making some money and then
I could maybe find get my foot in the
door somewhere because they gave a stat
like over 70% of co-op students got a
job with the company a good company they
were co-op in with and I that actually
happened with me I started working at
IBM because they also tell you how much
people pay and you know I was very
frugal and when somebody told me I can
start making money and elongate my
college career which I was enjoying it
was like a win-win for me and I was like
you know IBM pays the most
they paid like $17 $0.19 an hour I yeah
I don't remember numbers and I remember
that number seventeen ninety it meant a
lot to me I was like I'm gonna rake it
in back in 1998 so I did that I ended up
getting working for them full-time
afterward but it was kind of cool to go
for a semester and then come back and so
for me it wasn't that daunting I didn't
have that moment of oh crap now it's the
rest of my life do you remember feeling
that
I kind of eased into it
I liked working there and they extended
ex-senator job offer I didn't do the
coop but I did a summer I did a summer
at Black & Veatch that then led to my
job so I did sort of like a song co-op
so it's kind of a soft transition but
but I think that specifically - I I do
think that's good advice before we I
think my first piece of advice is if
you're if you're a student look for
something even if you don't get paid or
don't get paid much at all to gather
some to make connections and to get some
experience before you're out there and
then I think second of all even if you
haven't done that it's what do I do
after graduating it's like don't think
of it like the rest of your life think
about it just the next step well yeah
cuz it works totally different than they
used to I was gonna say specifically for
Taylor because we're talking about film
here is this is very different than
engineering like you can't just go off
and say I'm gonna do some engineering on
the side like you usual have to be with
an outfit or a firm or whatever does a
film major I would expect that Taylor
you are already creating things have
been creating things probably your whole
life but one thing that you should be
doing if you're not already doing is you
should be very actively pursuing your
own projects because you know we live in
a place now and in a time where with a
few hundred bucks which pretty much you
know most people can find a way to make
a few hundred bucks by working somewhere
or you know can get a digital camera and
a very cheap computer or even borrow
somebody's computer get some there's
free software like you're in a place now
where you can probably even use the
equipment at your school be creating a
lot of stuff because it's but any
creative career it's like when people
apply for to work a mythical
entertainment we do not look at their
GPA I mean some people put their GPA on
their resume like some people do like
when people are proud of it you know and
it's like three five or higher yeah
but many many times it is an indicator
but it's not we'd we'd first thing we
don't get we don't look
we don't really care what school you
went to we don't really care what your
GPA is when it comes to an entertainment
business what we care about is your
portfolio what you have to show where's
your what's your real what have you done
how does it apply to what it is that we
need and then what is your interview
like and do you feel like a good fit to
what we're trying to accomplish here so
I would just say that from when it's a
coup you have a there's sort of a
different way of approaching things when
you have a creative you're coming from a
creative background you should be
creating as much as possible because
it's probably gonna be some short film
or some video or some YouTube series or
something like that or just just a 1
minute of footage that's gonna get you
or beat up or being on a set and part of
a larger team I think you know find a
way to apply that no matter what your
your field of study is find a way to get
your feet wet before you got to jump
into the deep end of the tub mm asks
what can I make in the microwave to eat
that's not boring we're back in college
again gotta use that microwave as a main
form of cooking mmm well I've got a
great answer to this and I've
demonstrated how to make it on good
mythical morning before I call it the
cheese disc it's not boring at all it is
just one layer of Ritz crackers on a
plate with then shredded cheese
sprinkled on top of it to basically
create a cheese blanket you throw it you
can't have blue cheese if you're feeling
frisky then you put that thing in the
microwave for approximately 60 to 90
seconds and then you stand back you open
it up and you have a cheese frisbee that
can either be eaten or thrown tell me
what part of that is boring I'm
listening
silence yeah that's right crickets baby
because it's not boring it's the best
thing that you can do with a microwave
Lauren asks as parents are there any
hopes / fears you meaning us have with
our own kids getting closer to preparing
themselves for college mmm yeah Lily is
a freshman in high school so 4 years
from now she'll be in college it's crazy
it is crazy to think about that
yeah four years is not a long time yeah
and Locke says five years and he'll be
in college yeah this is a pretty fresh
subject for for me I was just having a
conversation with Locke about this last
night so
so data's our kids just last year made
the transition from homeschooling into
just a regular school public school
which I would say is going well yeah
yeah it's going great very well there
was a you know wasn't an great
transition like the first couple of
weeks they were a little freaked out and
Locke was freaked out about you know his
made all the work and and just you know
how what how am I being measured in all
this stuff but he's gotten into a groove
he's done very very well
but now he's in this place where these
other kids are talking about prepping
for college and it is so much more
competitive than it was when we were in
school so I remember when we were in
high school from 1992 to 1996 like AP
classes were a very new thing in fact I
I don't even know if my brother who was
just a few years older got college
credit for like AP like Advanced
Placement stuff right just because they
were like rolling the program out at
least in Harnett County they were
rolling it out in the 90s and so it was
very like we took ap physics and we went
to Michael jubie's house and just had
him explain what the heck was going on
with ap physics but we didn't take that
many AP classes but now there's all this
pressure to get all these AP courses if
you really want to get your first choice
in college and so Locke is very driven
he's very focused he's thinking about
his future his mind is in the future
he's very much like me but yet he's not
in Harnett County in 1992 so he's he's
in a different place and so his
mentality is like he's got this pressure
now we've put pressure on him almost
unknowingly because we kind of have this
like you got to do well you need to put
yourself in a position to be in a good
college because it determines the rest
of your life and just the way we talk
about academics I think has actually put
some unneeded pressure on him and so
just last night we're talking about how
we're trying to plan some stuff that
we're gonna do for the for the summer
which might involve some trips and some
vacations and that kind of thing and
then he's like well dad I've got two
sessions of summer school and I'm like
well let me look at the dates on this
thing and he basically has scheduled his
entire summer as school because he's
taking high school classes before he
gets to high school because he's like
dad I have to take this science so then
I can have more room for AP classes and
so then I can boost my GPA and get my
first choice college and that was like
but like we won't have the ability to
take like a real family vacation you
won't be able to go to some of these
basketball camps that you want to go to
you're gonna basically be in school and
with the very cut just a couple of short
breaks and I like had this moment where
I was like I feel like we've put this
undue pressure on him maybe it's just I
mean maybe a lot of it does come from
his own mind in the way that he is it's
kind of a role reversal whoa whoa whoa
we got to go on vacation it's an
interesting dynamic well because and
then I started like reading about like
there's a New York Times article which
is about all the pressure that kids have
now to like there's this it's it's super
interesting because it's this thing
we're like kids who are well-off
upper-middle class kids who have the
ability to pay for summer classes and
for expensive tutors and that kind of
thing they're getting all this benefit
from these AP classes but then the kids
who don't have as much money and don't
have as much support from their kids
from their parents who are the ones who
actually need the the increased exposure
to college they're not doing this stuff
that's kind of a whole different issue
it's just sort of an interesting picture
of the way that this has kind of created
this race to the finish for kids to get
ready for school but ultimately what
we've decided is he's not going to take
both sessions because I'm like I don't
want to look back and say you didn't get
to go to these cool places and go on
these cool trips and do these these
camps that you want to do which i think
is ultimately more enriching as a person
and I'm like you know what you may not
be able to get as many AP classes when
all is said and done but I don't want
your life to be completely defined by
just trying to have all this pressure to
succeed to just get into exactly the
right school
if that's going to make all the
difference in the world I don't know
we're just having I don't necessarily
have any specific advice about it but
it's it's it's it's very fresh
conversation for us yeah I think I'm I'm
I'm definitely not nearly as a futurist
in my thinking as you are instinctively
so for me it takes more discipline for
for for me to think about Wow in in in
in the next year or two we're gonna be
making some some concrete decisions
about where where Lily's gonna go when
she graduates but yeah you're exactly
right all of those decisions trickle
back to a year before now you know so I
start to feel behind when I hear you
talk about it which is kind of it kind
of freaks me out but I do think that our
experience in doing something and fun
and ourselves successful it's something
that we couldn't we couldn't have
declared as a major yeah I mean and it's
not prestigious we thought yeah we
thought we were gonna go to film school
that was that was a nixed before we even
left high school it just didn't happen
it didn't seem wise enough to you know
the people who were influencing us but
it turned out okay you know you take you
take it's a balance and I I think you
give a good example of maintaining that
balance of okay we've got to do we've we
should know everything that needs to be
done but then it may not be the wisest
choice to do all of that yeah it could
be quote successful you know it's I
think it's very important that we teach
our kids to to to listen to themselves
to get to know themselves as they're
becoming themselves cuz it could be so
they're so far from being who they're
going to be because it could be some
experience that they have over summer
and something they're trying a camp that
they go to a country that they travel to
which is important to a
they have the opportunity to do that I
think that that will probably ultimately
contribute to who they are as a person
more than just having all their ducks in
a row when it comes to being ready for
college and you know what maybe they
won't get into you know like Locke has
talked to black.we since he was a kid
he's like I want to go to Stanford and
hey you know and I'm like well that's an
incredibly difficult thing to do and I'm
all for it if you can work your way into
that situation but we come from a
totally different place like like
there's NC State is a great school for
what we did but it is not a school that
isn't particularly hard to get into it's
not in it's like we didn't have this
like pressure like it was a given that
we were a going to a state school we
weren't gonna go to a private school
that required a lot of money and B it
was gonna be in-state you know I think
at the time things have changed so much
but I think I remember our entire
college career at NC State cost like
$23,000 or something like that like it
was state state school especially
California state schools so much more
expensive than that now but I don't know
we need to move on to another question
but I just think that we're trying to
answer those questions right now and I
think that the bottom line is we're
trying to think about our kids as a
whole person and realize that it's not
just about the the academic success and
going to the right school because I
don't think you know I think that they
can get it can mess them up emotionally
and mentally if they apply this pressure
this is this developmental stage there's
there's so many things happening that I
just don't want to put too much pressure
especially when you start seeing that
they're putting pressure on themselves
mm-hmm
Heather asks what do you do when your
suite mate pees all over the toilet seat
PS my suite mate is a girl what we can't
help you there but I think your your
suite mate needs help Justin asked what
is some of the best ways to make the
cafeteria food taste better I would like
some better food for the rest of my time
that I'm here as
student I remember you know staying in
Syme dorm our freshman year every night
we were on the on the far that was bad
to have been the East East Campus east
side of campus and the dining hall was
on the basically a far west side of
campus and you remember every night like
we would we we'd gather like some
friends that lived on our Hall and you'd
make a pilgrimage it was a pilgrimage
all the way ugly raw opposite side
campus to get to the dining hall I I
just have really fond memories of that
moment it's like you're done with
classes you get back to your dorm room
everybody starts gathering up it's like
alright what what you guys ready to go
to the dining hall it's like every you
know it was a concerted effort it was
like a it was like a an expedition a
backpack expedition into like the
Everest or something
you got to get geared up like you're
bringing snacks you got a drink you know
it's like we gotta have something to
sustain us halfway by the time we get to
Turlington hall we're probably gonna
need to find a water fountain right so
that we can make it the rest of the way
and you also didn't want to show up at
the cafeteria alone yeah so it was like
there was this sense of like bring a
delegation yeah it was like bringing
your freaking delegation to the dining
hall it's one of my favorite memories of
being in college I doubt that this is
the way I just doubt that this there's
many people listening that this is their
press if they if they were in Syme dorm
I'm sure I don't know I think people I
think people are a lot more isolated oh
you mean now
now I thought you meant other people
back then but there are lots of
delegations and then by the time when
you got closer it all come together
because we were like we weren't
connecting again I'm not trying to sound
like an old crotchety man but what you
but I will say that we weren't
connecting with people via our phones
because we didn't have smart phones so
you made some legitimate connections
with the people in your dorm room
especially when you're walking across
country to get to there and then when
you get over it I don't remember
anything about the food except that
there was a whole machine
for chocolate milk oh yeah the chocolate
milk remember you go up to the thing
with chocolate in it it was a chrome box
with chocolate milk bag was a tube and
it had them had the white brownish tube
because the chocolate milk had stained
it over the years and then in front of
that there was like a mmm there was like
I'll just call it a ladle it was a heavy
metal ladle but instead of like being a
scooper it was it was like a knob on the
end of it and you would grab it you grab
it and you would lift it it was like it
was very medical it was like it was like
ow it was like he might as well have
been a cow's udder it was more like a
turning cough situation yeah but we were
in an agricultural school I think it
probably was like tied in to the milking
technology they were using on that part
of campus the knob was as big as the
palm of my hand and you you pick up a
handful of that metal and you lift up
the arm and then underneath it you put
your glass in the chocolate milk would
flow yeah yeah that made a beautiful
thing so I think my advice is just focus
on the experience the food's gonna taste
like crap just pour chocolate milk on it
well I was just gonna say hot sauce they
have that they're just you know you can
bring it in your hot sauce or take hot
sauce with you and that'll solve a world
of problem hot sauce in chocolate milk
let's let's close with a personal one
okay Morgan what's the most annoying
roommate habit you both had to deal with
in college possibly about the other
person and how did you deal with it so I
haven't really thought about this one
ahead of time I think I think mine how
did i annoy you I was annoyed this I
think this is more about me than about
you but I was annoyed at you that you
could so easily and without a tinge of
remorse or anxiety drop whatever studies
you were doing and play twisted metal
with Greg
and it wasn't that I wasn't invited or
that I felt left out that was just so
envious of your ability to just say all
that all this stack of stuff that I'm
supposed to be doing as a in my
collegiate endeavor Oh screw it
I'm just going to be over here having
fun like and I'm and maybe this is more
in retrospect but I don't know I know I
feel this way now looking back at the
college you I'm so annoyed that you had
that ability its envy well I I did study
you did study and I and I did well but I
didn't do as well as I would have if I
hadn't have decided that okay this is
enough and I was very influenced by
Greg's mentality which we've told this
story before but one time he was trying
to get me to stop studying and he came
into my dorm room and he said come on
let's go you know what you know you
don't learn anything that's what he said
as I was trying to study and I remember
you told me that you turned to me and
telling me that we and I'm like well
since that moment in college many
different times when anyone's trying to
get ready for something we've just said
you know what you know you don't learn
anything come on let's just do it
and you know what while that is entirely
not true because if you knew what you
knew there'd be no need for college you
you do you do learn things all the time
but the sentiment was come on man
this isn't the most important thing
right now and oh is that ready my mom
just made a strong bully that's it and
here's the thing about Greg's mom is
that she had this Stromboli that she
would make and she would freeze it yeah
she she when she came to visit him or
when he went back home he would come
back with these strombolis and then we
would put them in the toaster oven
cuz they were like cooked and frozen and
we just put him in the toaster oven and
this was like this is like the perfect
college taste you know what I'm saying
like a toaster oven falled it's like a
pizza and a blankie Stromboli and he'd
put that Stromboli in that toaster oven
we'd put on twisted metal on the
PlayStation and I would be the the
Cadillac that had that know the hearse
that would be the hearse that had the
the fire that came out of the headlights
I'd only think that's a character on the
game anymore and we would just play
twisted metal for hours and like that
you start smelling that toaster oven
heating up that Stromboli like if I
could smell that Stromboli in a toaster
oven and Greg's dorm right now it would
be it would fill me with so much joy you
can we can get a toaster oven and ask a
memory man and there was just something
about that experience that just I was
like this is what college is supposed to
be about twisted metal and Stromboli I
never once never tasted Rumble you never
you never came over to the Greg's room
and play the game never not once yeah
you didn't you missed out man yeah hey
we're having fun and I hate I hate you
for it well I'll tell you it's annoying
I'll tell you something about it on how
did i annoy you that speaks more about
your shortcomings as a person well it's
interesting because I feel like I did
not have a very good girl even though we
were best friends all growing up and
lived together through all throughout
college you know shared a room together
uh-huh
I don't think that I would have ever
been able to articulate your
sensitivities and your and how
particular you are about certain things
until having worked with you for all
these years like I wouldn't have
necessarily just said because I don't
think we knew ourselves very well I
don't think I would have said known a
lot about me personally or about you it
just we weren't thinking about those
things right so I don't think I would
have said that like well link is picky
or he's really particular about what
temperature is it is in our room and I
don't remember thinking any of those
things until like we started working
together every single day for a really
long time the thing that I remember and
I and it was a little annoying it was
also kind of amusing was when you were
still dating your girlfriend from high
school
so we're talking freshman year freshman
years I don't know what you're gonna say
but and you would talk to her on the
phone and you'd be curled up on the fly
on the bed you'd get into your bed and
you'd be laying there in your bed and
you'd kind of like be in the bunk bed
yes you would be in the bunk bed okay
and you'd be in the fetal position like
facing away from me so like kind of
creating this barrier and like having
your head on the pillow and like talking
into the phone and like the nature of
the your voice would be like it was like
baby talk to your girlfriend for like
maybe an hour and it happened a lot and
it was you forgotten about this that was
it so that was that was one type of
conversation you would happen of course
I was like still in the room I'm like
studying or doing whatever seating
stromboli whatever I was doing I think I
was making dying dog noises notes those
are distinctly different and then the
other conversation that you would have
which that this wasn't annoying because
you would be so quiet was when you were
talking to your mom and and you know you
you guys grew up together basically you
know your single mom seeing only only
child so you guys had like it's what she
was grown-up different she was the mom
and I was his child right but you know
I'm saying like it was the two of us
yeah yeah yeah so you kind of have a
different relationship with your mom and
like my mom would have to call me to
like track me down to like talk to me
your mom you would call you as well but
she called a lot more than my mom did
and you would you would literally just
be on the phone for like 45 minutes and
it would just be mm-hmm-hmm-hmm now greg
was a lot worse than me
at that there talking to his mom like
yes you're getting me confused with Greg
no no no but no but your mom you're
right I'm a tough guy Matt wasn't
annoyed by this cuz like I said you were
just being quiet but my mom loved me
more than your
mom loved your mom would just talk to
you and talk to you and like fill you in
on lots of things and you uh-huh and you
would just you're just there you were
you were just listening to I I still do
that now yeah but but you have to
remember that Gregg's conversations with
his mom were epic I don't work like I I
distinctly do he would have you be like
two hours on the phone with his mom no
and she would be doing all he put me to
shame
but that annoyed you the and why on it
the thing that Greg always tells if he
was here he always makes fun of me even
when we saw him we were on tour he's in
Washington State and he came in we saw
him after that show I think he brought
it up again but I was like a running
joke but he would say every every night
at a certain time which would be my
bedtime all of a sudden he would hear
ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding
this is Howie
this is him telling the story and he'd
be like well I know the links going to
bed because he's got his spoonful of
peanut butter and then he's he's poured
Nesquik into his chocolate milk and he's
stirring his chocolate milk in his glass
with his peanut butter spoon and that
annoyed him to no end that every night
it would he wherever he was in the
apartment probably playing twisted
meadow with you I'd be back in my room
like I'm going to bed now no but on my
study yes but but I think it's I think
it's the combination of how systematic
it is and how aggressive you are
everything like that
the uhq very aggressively used but I
would grow it be in my room like I would
drink it in my room right but inside but
it would it's it's coming out thank God
like if you were to want him if you were
to walk in and see you doing it you'd be
like one like there's there's a very
aggressive intentionality to the way
that you do the things that you've
settled it was twice and I'm sure it was
a certain number yeah I mean I don't
recall that but but I
I can relate to it and you know what I
wish you the best in your schooling
careers it seems to me you were saying I
didn't get to say this that uh that
locks definitely going to Community
College yeah yeah ultimately that's yeah
we made the decision it's no I didn't I
didn't want to leave that stone unturned
in all your Community College talk I
let's go order a four-year college
degree or no we're not really expecting
that anymore
so we wish you the best in if you're
studying if you're supposed to be
studying right now and you haven't been
well get back to it oh you know what
you know what you know you don't learn
anything yeah exactly play some twisted
metal
go eat a Stromboli do it yourself a
peanutbutter spoon dip it in some milk
and stir up that chocolate syrup do they
allow toaster ovens and college dorms
anymore probably not so no no you know
warming up in your pocket just get a hot
pocket we had a guy that worked here for
a while we put a hot pocket in his
pocket and literally heat it that way do
that that's very college talk at you
next week
[Music]